[Musik]
[Applaus]
im Anschluss hören Sie die Worte der
hohen Geistlichkeit
geschätzte ehren- und Festgäste liebe
Angehörige und vor allem liebe
anzugelobene Rekruten heute ist es
soweit ihr Soldat sein wird mit einem
würdigen Festakt gefeiert
damit sind sie herausgefordert das
Vertraute zurückzulassen und sich
aufzumachen hinein in neuerfahrungen
es gibt jetzt Gesetze und
Verpflichtungen Uniform und Waffe
Befehle und Vorgesetzte aber auch die
Chance auf Kameradschaft
viel wird von Ihnen gefordert aber im
Leben eines jeden Menschen gibt es
Herausforderungen sich auf Neues
auch auf wichtiges einzulassen auch
abraham ist es so ergangen und Gott der
Herr sprach zu Abraham geht von deiner
Verwandtschaft und aus deines Vaters
Haus in ein Land das ich dir zeigen will
und ich will dich segnen und du sollst
ein Segen sein ich denke ähnlich wie dem
Abraham geht es jetzt auch Ihnen als
Rekruten auch sie sind gefordert für den
Dienst das elterliche Haus zu verlassen
auch sie betreten ein neues Land das
ihnen gezeigt wird aber solche
Herausforderungen sind wichtig im Leben
weil sie uns in Bewegung halten weil sie
uns weiterbringen
ich möchte Sie ermutigen das Beste aus
ihnen und ihrem Dienst zu machen denn
der Dienst für die anderen für die
Allgemeinheit für ihre Kameraden und für
die Gemeinschaft in unserem Land zahlt
sich aus ich bin der festen Überzeugung
dieser Dienst ist unbezahlbar
wir brauchen in unserer Welt immer
Menschen die anpacken und helfen wo
Hilfe nötig ist Menschen haben das zu
allen Zeiten erkannt und sich für die
Allgemeinheit und die Gesellschaft
engagiert
und als Christen sind wir von Gott in
den Dienst genommen damit seine Welt
wieder ein Stück weiter mehr
Wirklichkeit wird und ganz ehrlich eine
größere Zusage kann niemand von uns
bekommen als ich bin bei dir alle Tage
bis an der Welt Ende
diese Zusage dass Gott uns nicht allein
lässt keinen einzigen von uns
das ist aber auch sein Auftrag an uns
dass wir dort wo wir sind und Wirken für
andere zum Segen werden
also gehen Sie mit dieser Zusage Gottes
in ihren Grundwehrdienst gemeinsam mit
ihren Kameraden
Vorgesetzten Kommandanten Familien und
Freunden denn so spricht der HERR
ich will dich segnen und du sollst ein
Segen sein Amen
sehr geehrter Herr Briger dir heute
Festgäste liebe Angehörige Liebe
anzugehobene Rekruten
in wenigen Augenblicken werdet es wird
jetzt hier eure
angelobungsformel sprechen und das
letzte Wort diese Formel ist bekanntlich
zu dienen
zu dienen bedeutet nicht immer dass man
nur das macht was einem befohlen wird
oder dass man etwas tut nach der
Vorschrift oder der für das wofür man
ein Geld oder sonst was kriegt
zu dienen bedeutet ganz was anderes
zu dienen bedeutet dann wenn es
notwendig ist wenn das der Moment aber
erfordert das tut tun
das was ist notwendig ist was zu helfen
ist zu tun ist und zwar mit dem ganzen
Einsatz mit dem ganzen Herzen es gibt
einige Berufe wo das zu denen sehr
wichtig ist und man kann die Qualität
dieser
berufsausübenden Menschen daran messen
wie sehr sie dieses zu dienen sich zu
Herzen nehmen und ernst nehmen Sie
wissen dass es gute Lehrer gibt
Lehrerinnen die mehr gemacht haben als
nur das Notwendige für die ihre Schüler
es gibt auch Menschen zum Beispiel
Polizisten oder Feuerwehrleute wie heute
auf der Rax
und es gibt natürlich auch Soldaten oder
Menschen die also auch diese Ausbildung
gemacht haben und die dir den anderen
Menschen in Not sehen Menschen die
Schutz und Hilfe brauchen und die Frage
nicht lang und die machen das so wie
heute auch die Ärzte Ärztinnen die
Pflegekräfte an den Intensivstationen
die die schwerkranken
Patienten pflegen und zwar oft so dass
sie auf an die Grenzen ihre physischen
und psychischen Möglichkeiten gehen
und so möchte ich dass der Gott der Herr
euren
friedenstiftenden und Einsatz
reichen Dienst mit Herzen mit vollen
Einsatz segnen
der Vater und der Sohn und der Heilige
Geist Amen
ihr tretet Liebe Rekruten und euch alle
Familien in einen neuen Lebensabschnitt
ein
für die Familien bedeutet das Lernen ist
immer mehr
so möchte ich für euch und mit euch und
vielleicht Familien beten
Herr unser Gott
diese junge Menschen leisten ihren
Dienst für die Menschen dieses Landes
gib ihnen Kraft und Freude
ihren Auftrag im Geist der christlichen
oder humanistischen Kameradschaft und
Nächstenliebe zu leisten
begleite sie mit deinem Segen damit sie
nicht Schaden erleiden
im Dienst oder auch außerhalb des
Dienstes
schenke ihren kommentanten die Weisheit
ihrer gute Vorgesetzte zu sein und halte
deine schützende Hand über alle Menschen
die schwer haben
gott segne euch eure Angehörigen und
alle die für euch Mitverantwortung
tragen
[Musik]
es spricht nun der militärisch
höchstanwesende Brigadier Magister Spali
anzuwälder das eindrückungstermines
Oktober 21 hohe Geistlichkeit die fest
und Ehrengäste vor allem auch sie Werte
Angehörige
ganz bewusst habe ich sie
dir angelogenen Hand zu gelungenen des
eindrückungstermines Oktober 2021 an die
Spitze meiner Worte gestellt denn sie
sind das die heute im Mittelpunkt stehen
es ist heute ihr Tag
sie haben sich freiwillig zum Dienst mit
der Waffe beim österreichischen
Bundesheer entschieden
und werden ihrem Land dienen die hohe
Geistlichkeit hat das schon ausgedrückt
was wir darunter verstehen
dieses gerade
in dieser herausfordernden Zeit in der
wir gerade Leben in der das
österreichische Bundesheer mehr denn je
gebraucht wird sehr zu respektieren
das österreichische Bundesheer leistete
und leistet als strategischer Reserve
des Landes einen wesentlichen Beitrag
zur Bekämpfung der corona-krise und ist
zusätzlich in vielfältigen Einsätzen im
In- und Ausland gebunden
gerade jetzt unterstützen Kräfte des
Bundesheer bei der Bekämpfung der
Waldbrände im Bereich der Rax die
Hubschrauber wurden sogar vom
Heldenplatz am Nationalfeiertag direkt
abgezogen und hier bei der
Brandbekämpfung zu helfen
genau diese Einsatz Wahrscheinlichkeit
wird auch in Zukunft sehr hoch bleiben
und es ist durchaus möglich dass Sie die
Anzahl gelobenden das
einrichtungstermines Oktober 21 auch in
den Einsatz gehen werden
aber eben diese corona-krise hat eine
Angelobung am Heldenplatz am
Nationalfeiertag vor zwei Tagen nicht
möglich gemacht die Einschränkungen
haben es nicht möglich gemacht eine groß
angelogen zu machen
dennoch bin ich überzeugt
dass die heutige ihre Angelobung ebenso
beeindruckend sein wird wie es für mich
meine war die zugehörigermaßen schon ein
paar Jahre zurückliegt
in wenigen Minuten werden Sie
gelöbnisformel sprechen und dann darin
geloben unser Vaterland und sein Volk zu
schützen das Wohl der Gesellschaft über
das eigene zu stellen eigene Bedürfnisse
hinter jene der Gemeinschaft
zurückzustellen ist eine Einstellung
welche nicht hoch genug zu bewerten ist
mit diesem Dienst an unserer
Gesellschaft denn sie für die nächsten
Monate leisten werden leisten sie alle
eine nicht hoch genug einzuschätzenden
Beitrag für die Sicherheit aller
Bewohner Österreichs
ich bin überzeugt dass die vor ihnen
liegenden Monate interessant aber auch
fordernd sein werden aber das vor allem
die gelebte Kameradschaft diese Zeit für
sie prägen wird und dafür möchte Ihnen
ganz persönlich viel Soldaten Glück
wünschen es lebe das österreichische
Bundesheer es lebe unsere geliebte
Heimat die Republik Österreich
[Musik]
Rekruten spricht mir nach
ich glaube
mein Vaterland
die Republik Österreich
und sein Volk zu schützen
und mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
ich glaube
den Gesetzen und den gesetzmäßigen
Behörden
[Applaus]
Treue und Gehorsam zu leisten
boah Alter eine Befehle meiner
Vorgesetzten
[Applaus]
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit all meinen Kräften
der Republik Österreich
und dem österreichischen Volk
zu dienen
[Musik]
zum Abschluss erfolgt nun die bitte an
den militärisch höchstanwesenden um
weitere Befehle und der Ausmaß des
fahnenprobst
gerade ich bedanke mich bei allen Gästen
hier vor Ort und den zusehen wir
Internet wir Livestream dass sie uns
beigewohnt haben bei diesem Festakt und
im Anschluss können die Verwandten
ihre
Rekruten natürlich begrüßen
[Musik]
[Applaus]